hey guys Pete peppers here and we're
going to talk about one of the game
features in candy crush jelly these are
the monk Ling's this first came out in
level 121 and they are a imaginary
creature that's like a baby monkey but
they don't they're not born they're
actually hatched from eggs I guess
that's a good indication that they're
not the same as monkeys so a little
pop-up here is telling us that we have
to match candies to make them and you
know this little egg and it fills up as
we make our matches it's up at the top
here and you can see that as we collect
orange candies they go up there there's
two orange squares on the board and
we're there that's once this fills up
that they'll go in that spot either one
of those spots and now it's telling us
that we have to get them below the candy
screen to collect them so they're sort
of like the bubble Bears and soda
except here there's no soda so they
don't float up you're actually just
trying to bring them down drop them down
with the natural gravity of the board so
that's not a real complicated process
it's important things to think keep in
mind this every every orange candy that
we match will fill this up so this one
fills up pretty fast on some some levels
you have to collect a lot more it just
depends and these orange squares they
can always go you can you can keep
adding them on the board that's not like
a limit of one as long as they're clear
so let's see if I can sweet make that
point here in a second right so here you
know with whenever he's sitting in the
square another one can't go in that
Square here we have two on this board so
the next one will go over here but there
will be boards later on where there only
be one Square and view and we won't be
able to
you know until we cleared out we won't
be able to get this this next one on the
board so that's pretty that's pretty all
of its pretty Excel explanatory it's
it's a pretty easy to understand feature
altogether special candies are obviously
going to help out when we were doing it
a stripe in the same row as the actual
monk laying is really good you know like
a vertical stripe here would drop them
all the way to the bottom the other
thing that I like is the wrapped candies
like you see there it's going to clear
the road twice and it's gonna move it
down pretty quickly this is the last one
we have to collect here but since we
have six members I'll just show you
even though well I'm not gonna do I'll
show you for the finish but even though
we have the member that we need to
collect more as you're coming on the
board beyond that like we could have six
or seven on there until we get five
ahead of the string they'll just keep
coming so that doesn't really play a
factor here but it can come in handy
later when you have to get a bunch of
them so the like I said the strategy is
to always pay attention to where your
orange squares are always pay attention
to how your meter is sometimes you won't
want to there was a really hard level
lately there was a level one seventy one
and it took a whole lot of orange
candies to fill this up so there was
there was some strategy stuff where he
had to think about like we you know when
it was empty you wanted to use your you
wanted to use your big combos that we're
gonna get a lot in there but like if it
was almost full then you would have to
think about like maybe I want to wait to
set that off to one and seventy so I can
get the full collection so you know
you're always going to want to be
thinking
about things like that there's something
I don't know I don't know if these coils
actually stop I guess I won't even be in
a case but you can see like on this one
that though that it's actually taking
more more orange candies than the last
one did so you're just when you're you
know when you start the level out just
kind of pay attention to you know is it
a quick level or slow level that will
help you decide whether you should be
trying to get more of them on the board
or moving them down as fast as possible
other levels will also have they'll have
scrolling boards so you might want to
think like about they it works the same
way the bear does the when it's
scrolling it's going to it's gonna
follow the bear so you know you might
want to keep it towards the top of the
board
so that you can get another one to hatch
before you move on because depending on
where the next um you know where the
next orange square effort to be hatched
is you know it might be the right idea
another thing to keep in mind is you
know whenever you're when you're
thinking about collecting orange it's
not necessarily just matching them you
know you see that fish got that one it
put it up there also earlier I didn't
really point it out but sweet you know
when you fire a striped candy off if it
hits orange candies on the way of those
collect them too so like a color bomb
for example will collect a whole bunch
all at once if you use it to collect the
orange candies or coloring candy can do
the same thing so here we are really
have two moves are really close to
hatching it I don't know if it's gonna
work out what city
yeah it did but I won't be able to get
it to drop in one move I don't think it
was no match this is gonna be sitting
right on the line or if I match the
yellow it's not gonna fall far enough so
yeah that's how you fail at a monk legs
level right here and you talk about the
other stuff and you don't concentrate on
get it done in time we'll set off this
fish and see if that makes some kind of
crazy thing happen but it didn't so
that's the that's the bit that's the
basic gist I don't want to make this
super long video keep in mind how fast
your egg at the top is filling up try to
collect the orange ones to get the
mullings on the board as fast as you
need to you're gonna have obstacles in
the way you're gonna have blockers
different things so you're just gonna
want to strategize because you know
ultimately you're gonna pick up some
orange matches in cascades so you just
sort of have to balance like you know
the goal of like am i trying to get it
they're trying to get a lot of them down
there fast or am i trying to clear the
way first and then get one to drop so
just think about stuff like that
I hope you've know a whole lot more
about monk Ling's now if you have any
questions leave a comment below please
subscribe to my channel to support all
these how-to videos I make and we'll
talk to you soon thanks